monsieur à les gabians bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
tout d'abord pour mieux comprendre un
petit peu la situation quelles sont
véritablement les enjeux pour
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie dans ce
conflit bah disons que l'azerbaïdjan a
intérêt à changer un statu quo qui lui
est défavorable de reconquérir des
territoires qui avait été perdu lors de
la guerre de 88 94 mais aussi il s'agit
d'un enjeu de politique interne
l'azerbaïdjan est un pays qui est
structurellement en faillite ou en prêt
faillite politique vu la captation de la
rente pétrolière par là le pouvoir d
alief donc il ya un besoin si vous
voulez de déclencher une nouvelle guerre
pour acheter la paix sociale
alors ce qui est inquiétant aujourd'hui
on voit bien que cet endroit de
mercenaires combien même le nombre de
ces mercenaires recrutés dans le nord de
la syrie et en libye par les services
turc n'est pas avéré le chiffre exact
mais ce qui est très abstrait important
c'est que on parle quand même d'un état
l'état près du relais qui est un état
souverain et qui a cédé tout un pan de
sa souveraineté à l' aventurisme du
président turquie en train de jouer les
pyromanes
ça veut dire quoi servent ils l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise le budget de la défense
à 100 pages à l'aise et très important
c'est l'équivalent du pib de l'arménie
la masa badge à nice n'a pas besoin de
mercenaires ils ont du matériel
israélien russes et les turcs dernier
cri donc à l'évidence le pour les
attirer il s'agit d'une partie de quitte
ou double pour si vous voulez affaiblir
l'arménie et négocier en position de
force pour la turquie ce qui est train
de se passer aussi est très important
parce que c'est non seulement une
manière d'allumer un nouveau front
caucase mais d'affaiblir la russie en la
poussant dans ses retranchements
la russie qui est un allié stratégique
de l'arménie métier aussi un allié de là
était un ami l'azerbaïdjan puisqu'elle
vend des armes ou deux parties n'a pas
intérêt à ce que le statu quo soit
modifiée sur sur le terrain parce que
si elle perdrait si vous voulez sa
stature de médiateurs alors irles le
président emmanuel macron a déclaré que
300 combattants djihadistes ont quitté
justement la syrie pour gagner le
territoire azerbaïdjanais 1 en
transitant par la turquie il demande des
explications à ankara est ce que la
france peut faire pression justement sur
la turquie selon vous les où le souci
c'est que la france est en travers la
relation franco-turque que traverse une
période de turbulences donc il n'y aura
peut-être pas forcément une marge de
manoeuvre importante de la part de la
diplomatie française mais il faut
prendre très au sérieux et aussi prendre
en considération les déclarations des
présidents macron parce que c'est elle
crée un précédent c'est la première fois
qu'on a un chef d'état occidental
membres de l'otan du conseil de sécurité
non permanent du conseil de sécurité qui
si vous voulez attirer l'attention de
l'opinion internationale sur la gravité
des enjeux nous sommes vraiment dans une
nouvelle phase on peut plus parler du
comté du karabagh comme on parlait
précédemment c'était pas un affrontement
internet ni quand
c'est véritablement une nouvelle donne
qui est en train de se jouer mais
j'ajoute à cela et si vous permettez
puisque c'est l'occasion de le dire on a
dit beaucoup d'inepties sur le karabagh
notamment l' agence de lagence la fp qui
relaie dans ces médias qui qualifie ce
territoire arménien historiquement
arménien deux régions séparatistes de
l'azerbaïdjan peuplé d'arméniens c'est
absolument faux le karabagh est une
république arménienne autoproclamée en
91 qui a déclaré son indépendance non
pas vis-à-vis batum et à vis de l'urss
en septembre 80 c'était encore l'union
soviétique
c'était un territoire qui à la base vous
laissera qui avait été détaché de
l'arménie par staline en 21 et au bout
de trois ans de guerre
d'autodétermination ne pouvons pas
revenir dans le giron de la mère patrie
a déclaré son indépendance vis-à-vis de
l'union soviétique
j'insiste sur la gravité sur du demo
puisque les mots ont un sens donc à
l'évidence on peut pas parler de ce
territoire comme une région séparatiste
comme c'est le cas dans les principaux
médias à statte ajoute qu' une des
perspectives
de solution politique à cette à ce
conflit interminable
ce serait de que le karabagh en tant
qu'acteur puisse revenir à la table des
négociations dans le cadre de l'ouest et
dernière question vous avez parlé de la
russie on sait que moscou est liée à
l'arménie par l'organisation du traité
de sécurité collective
quel rôle peut-elle à son tour je vais
justement dans ce conflit et trouver
peut-être une solution pacifique
là c'est parce que c'est parce que je
jouais en ville en bilatéral voir en
trilatéral entre paris moscou et ankara
on a l'impression qu'il ya un partage
des rôles entre le président maquereau
et le président poutine
vu le contexte il existe une certaine
peter dépendance dans la relation franco
russe au turc puisque la russie est un
pays qui exporte beaucoup de gaz à la
turquie
donc les lélés si vous voulez il ya
plusieurs plusieurs paramètres qui
doivent être pris en compte le problème
pour la russie si vous voulez c'est
xavier l'azerbaïdjan on a l'impression
qu'ils sont ils ont perdu
progressivement la main depuis les
affrontements de l'été dernier en
juillet de cette année il ya eu des
affrontements graves à la frontière
arméno azerbaïdjanaises et qui s'était
traduit par une avancée militaire en
tout cas un revers militaires azéri et
au plan diplomatique bas coûts avait
remplacé son ministre des affaires
étrangères qui était à un diplomate de
carrière proche du kremlin un ancien
diplomate soviétique il a remplacé par
un idéologue donc très nationaliste très
sensible à l'idéologie peinture qui est
donc elle il faut bien avoir à
l'évidence que la turquie l'azerbaïdjan
se considère comme une même nation en
deux états et le président macron a bien
compris si vous voulez la réalité de
cette menace qui pointe à l'horizon des
arméniens merci beaucoup
tigran les avions d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et auteur du livre minorités
d'orient elle les oubliés de l'histoire